the 1992 movie candyman still remains an
influential piece of horror cinema
now the highly anticipated sequel in the
franchise is almost here
for the fans who have been waiting
patiently here's everything we know so
far
candyman has seen quite a bit of
reshuffling over the last year universal
originally planned for the horror sequel
to come out in june 2020 but
by april of that year the studio pushed
it back in the schedule the studio set a
new aspirational release date for
september of that year but it had to
switch dates several more times
before it landed at its current date of
august 27
2021. it looks like candyman will stick
with that date but we can never be too
sure with these things
as far as we know candyman will come out
exclusively in theaters upon its initial
release
a ton of studios have begun
experimenting with dual theater and
streaming service release strategies
still
it looks like universal wants people to
have the chance to see the newest horror
flick on the big screen
at least initially there's no official
word yet regarding when or where the
slasher flick will be available to view
at home but it's likely to follow the
standard progression from theaters to
pay-per-view video on demand
to subscription streaming so don't
expect to watch it from your home until
it's concluded the standard theatrical
run
some films are delayed for creative
reasons nothing makes a fan base nervous
like a round of reshoots and if they're
extensive enough
they can definitely inspire a little
schedule shuffling fortunately that
wasn't the case with candyman the
original june 2020 release was rendered
unworkable by the budding pandemic
universal clearly didn't want to drop a
highly anticipated tentpole film on a
country full of empty theaters so
the first delay came down just as the
pandemic was picking up speed pushing
candyman back in overly
optimistic five months to september the
next delay sadly was also a result of
the ongoing pandemic
the pandemic dragged on into 2021 and
continues to drag on in many places
around the world
theaters around the world were still
shuttered as of 2021 so
instead of kicking the film to video on
demand universal pushed the release date
again
and again eventually landing on august
27th
with the domestic vaccine rollouts
significantly stemming the tide of the
pandemic and
lockdown orders lifting just about
everywhere in the u.s it now seems
almost certain that the august release
date will hold
unless something totally unforeseen
happens between now and then
expect candyman to roll into a theater
near you alongside the dog days of
summer
fans of the original candyman movies can
expect to see a few familiar faces among
the cast
most notably tony todd reprises his role
as the title slasher
the candy man himself is a terrifying
spirit who visits anyone who dares to
say his name
five times while looking into a mirror
with a rusty hook as a hand and a
propensity for bees
he's one of the scariest horror movie
monsters to grace the big screen
another original actor to return
includes vanessa estelle williams who
plays anne-marie mccoy in
both movies you may remember her from
the 1992 film as anthony's mother
who spoke with a college student about
the urban legend surrounding the monster
within chicago's cabrini green community
anthony is all grown up for the
follow-up and yaya abdulmatin ii
portrays him this time around
he's now a visual artist living in the
newly gentrified area of town where he
explores the myth of candyman to find
inspiration for his art the impressive
cast for the upcoming horror flick also
includes such talented
actors as tiana paris from one division
coleman domingo from morainey's black
bottom
and nathan lloyd stuart jarrett from
mope given that 2021's candyman doesn't
have a subtitle or any numbers in the
title it might be easy for audiences to
assume it's a remake of the original
rest assured it's a sequel that picks up
several decades after the first film's
events
the two movies even share a connection
by making the little boy candy man
kidnapped the protagonist of this
follow-up
as for the 2021 film the plot follows
anthony played by abdulmatine ii
as he seeks to find a way to rejuvenate
his art career one day he meets with an
older member of the community who was
once a resident of the cabrini green
projects
this person tells him the haunting story
of candyman which anthony then uses as
inspiration for his paintings however
the deeper he goes into exploring the
concept of candyman
the more he'll unleash a horrific wave
of murders
the director of the 2021 film nia
decosta appeared in a video interview in
which she discussed her approach to
candyman in depth
the director is clearly a kindred spirit
with her latest collaborator jordan
peele
decosta confirms that she shares peel's
firmly held belief that horror is a
perfect vehicle for the exploration of
social issues like racial and class
inequities
she pointed out in the interview that
the creation of monsters is hardly the
sole province of genre fiction
decosta says we create monsters of men
all the time people are murdered and
they become either saints
or they are vilified so throughout the
last year and a half
it was always coming back to that truth
horror is a really effective tool when
it comes to telling stories about things
that
impact us on a social level the very
function of it is to make you
uncomfortable and
i think if that discomfort is attached
to explorations of race or gender
you have to then reconcile your feelings
about race and gender
given the vocal sentiments of decosta
and horror maestro jordan peel
expect a healthy serving of the latter's
signature blend of frights and
social commentary to be on abundant
display
candyman is one horror film that will
leave you thinking twice
before you stare too long at a mirror
and say candy
don't say that we already know that
candyman 2021 has been pulled forward
into the modern day as a result we can
expect the film to grapple with
contemporary issues of anti-black racism
in america
using the popular discourse of the time
peel has also described this film as a
spiritual
sequel to the original candyman one that
will likely capture the mood of the
original better than
any of its less lauded direct sequels
for a hint at how
peel's new vision might look we turn to
universal's extensive synopsis of the
forthcoming film
universal revealed for as long as
residents can remember
the housing projects of chicago's
cabrini green neighborhood were
terrorized by a word of mouth ghost
story about a supernatural killer with a
hook for a hand
easily summoned by those daring to
repeat his name five times into a mirror
in present day a decade after the last
of the cabrini towers were torn down
visual artist anthony mccoy and his
girlfriend gallery director brianna
cartwright
move into a luxury loft condo in cabrini
now gentrified beyond recognition
and inhabited by upwardly mobile
millennials
universal further explains saying with
anthony's painting career on the brink
of stalling
a chance encounter with a cabrini green
old timer exposes anthony to the
tragically horrific nature of the true
story behind candyman
anxious to maintain his status in the
chicago art world anthony begins to
explore these macabre details in his
studio as fresh grist for paintings
unknowingly opening a door to a complex
past that unravels his own
sanity and unleashes a terrifying wave
of violence
that puts him on a collision course with
destiny it's worth noting
that though the cabrini green
neighborhood still exists the real-life
cabrini green row house projects were
torn down in 2011.
the cabrini green housing projects were
infamous and provided an iconic backdrop
to the original 1992 candyman
just how the new film will grapple with
the changing face of the neighborhood
is unknown but counts on jordan peel to
find an interesting way to weave the
complex social fabric of
present-day chicago into aesthetic or
plot devices to the thesis of this film
after over a year of delays there better
be a trailer fortunately universal has
released not just one but two
full-length trailers to keep viewers
excited about the film over the course
of the excruciating weight
both trailers taken in tandem tease a
terrifying and relevant film
marked by immaculate acting direction
and
cinematography the first trailer
released back in february 2020 when that
original june release date still seemed
like a possibility
shows off quite a bit of the two killer
leads yaya abdulmatian ii
and tiana paris we also get a glimpse of
a bunch of teenagers lined up in what
looks like a school bathroom
summoning the titular candy man while
standing in front of a mirror
you know like you're supposed to do it
miner spoiler alert
it doesn't end well for the teams the
second trailer which only dropped on
june 23
2021 takes an even creepier approach it
opens with a bit of animated shadow
puppetry to accompany a voice over
explaining the candyman mythology and
hinting at the danger that will be
summoned in the film
interestingly the plot of the original
candyman film seems to serve as the lore
underpinning the contemporary story
the voiceover sets up the razer blades
in the candy scenario from the earlier
film
as quick intercuts of the animated
shadow puppets continue to intrude to
eerie effect for the fans that want to
see how these things are all pulled
together
and the ones who just want a few good
scares candyman is almost here
we just have to make our way into the
theaters for the experience
say his name looks like we're going to
finally find out what happens when they
do
in theaters on august 27th check out one
of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you